[Music]  we're all such huge fans of glow at  glider and I know this is the upcoming  last season what what can you tease and  when are you filming oh goodness I don't  think I can tease anything because I  truly don't know I've been trying to ply  it out you know we're out of Vegas for  sure so I know that and we start  shooting at the beginning of March I'll  be directing an episode again this  season so I can tell you that I thank  you I really don't know i mean i i'm i  i'm assuming that debbie is gonna be  running her network that she just bought  and i'm very curious to see where we  find ruth on her journey and I hope  those ladies reunite as soon as possible